who do you think is satoshi nakamoto
is it possible that you are in fact
satoshi nakamoto
no uh you know
if you you you have a preponderance of
the evidence
uh i think the most likely candidate
would be adam back
it's the occam's razor candidate and
mostly because
he's the right place right time right
age right skill set
you know if you look at the design of
bitcoin the types of decisions like the
use of fourth the scripting language
it was pretty common in english and
european pedagogy in the 1980s and 1990s
it's like an example
language for a stack based assembly and
like little stuff like that little
quirks like that
also he created hashcash which is the
predecessor of proof-of-work he's kind
of got a chip on his shoulder that
microsoft never did anything with it
so he's probably looking for something
he grew up with all the cypherpunks he
knew of hal finney
you know he knew of all these people um
he knew phil's everybody
well no because the the the code was not
good enough
um hal was a unix linux guy he was a
talented programmer
he was a talented developer the initial
code for bitcoin was developed to look
like on a windows machine
you know adam worked at microsoft go
figure and also it was very academic and
it had to be cleaned up and a lot of
things had to be
patched up and fixed if it got like hell
developed it
it probably had less of the you know
let's use sec p256 k1 and
these types of things and more of like
hey let's build this cool engineering
thing
and we'll figure out the protocol design
later on it just stinks
of an older academic the initial design
of bitcoin
and the initial rollout of bitcoin and
then brilliant people like craig maxwell
and others they came and
cleaned it all up and lo and behold
where's adam like the ceo of the largest
bitcoin development company in the space
who's trying to keep working on and
building out
bitcoin and where the hell was adam when
satoshi was around
i don't i don't think there was any
overlap where they were pulled together
at the same period of time
but i mean if you really care you can if
you're you know you can even do this
there's a lovely paper written by the us
army
um if you just google like code
stellametry us army
it's a technique where you can use ml
and a few other things to actually kind
of develop a fingerprint for the way
that people write code
so all you got to do is take the
original bitcoin source code
and then take all the open source repos
from around that time period
and before and see if there's a match
between those two
now if he's really good at creating an
alias
probably not so good at obfuscating the
code that was written
so the odds are that you'd probably find
a match to a repo that's connected to a
real life human identity
or at least a weaker opsec because you
know
you're younger you have weaker opsec do
you know if people have tried that i
don't think anybody's actually done it
but there's actually a beautiful paper
it's like 94 percent accurate the codes
telomeres
so of um for various reasons
i've worked with people that work on
stylometry of natural language
okay uh the and i think it matches
closest to nick
sabo if you actually do the the the
written stylometry analysis of satoshi's
writings
too so i i meant salamat as a field i
didn't actually look for application
for this particular problem but so
you're saying nyx alba is the closest
match
yeah somebody did it years i didn't look
if the model was sound or not but i just
remember reading on a bitcoin talk and
asabo is another one of the common
candidates hal finisabo
and adam are probably the top three
things that people
you